you've said fortune 500 companies are as  important in the opioid response as the  medical community what do you mean by  that  well giving example would you ever had a  family member or a friend who's gone  through recovery you know how hard it is  to get a job you know I think there's  two really important non-medical pieces  to success one is obviously the  individual's spiritual connection  whatever it is and trying to get through  this the other is to be able have the  dignity of a job and it is not easy so I  do think the fortune 500 countries have  an enormous amount to play to helping  celebrate the success of young people  and old people that actually go into  recovery and and help solidify that  recovery by helping them have the  dignity of a job